last week we had a
somewhat extensive discussion about the
recently released but long discussed
together trial
a trial
of several different drugs there were
several different arms to the study
one of them was about ivermectin and its
effectiveness for
covid
and
we learned seven months ago that the
conclusion of the study was that
ivermectin was ineffective but we waited
seven months to see the methods and
there was a feature of what was finally
published in the new england journal of
medicine
that caught several of us off guard
including me it looked as if a bunch of
people had mysteriously disappeared from
the placebo group
turns out that was not correct so what i
said last week is not in fact an error
in the way that we thought it was that
said
there are
several groups that i'm aware of one of
which i'm a participant in that are
looking deeply into the together trial
and it is amazing how many
uh features of the method seem
non-standard and potentially
uh dangerous i won't say more but
not not just
the method as it was described in
advance but the method as it plays out
in real time as it plays out in real
life as it is actually applied like the
method that they claim to have used
doesn't seem to be the method they broke
they broke with method in several places
right now the one thing i want to point
out here in addition to the correction
which i believe is necessary and i think
we've been very careful to make
corrections when we've gotten things
wrong which is inevitable and in this
case we weren't the only people who got
this wrong because it was the obvious
interpretation even though it was not
the correct interpretation
but
i'm now watching
a group of something like 10 people
some of them absolutely experts in this
exact location whether it be experts in
how clinical trials are run experts in
medicine and the treatment of kovid i'm
watching these folks grapple with simply
understanding what happened
right
this is what was done according to the
manuscript that is supposed to be
a a recipe for replication
right a recipe for replication and we
are approximately a zillion miles from
enough information to replicate the
trial right we are still grappling with
understanding even what happened and not
in trivial ways in ways that are
absolutely central to whether or not the
conclusions of the study mean what they
claim to mean and i must say that that
is jaw-dropping let's assume that it's
honest in origin we cannot have science
where
10 smart people who know what you need
to know to understand what happened
cannot unpack the simple description of
how the
study was done right that should never
be the case because as you and i know
from having written dissertations
it is incredibly common that if you look
at the title and the abstract of the
paper and then you look at the methods
that you discover that actually the
title and the abstract are not justified
by what was done right yeah so so
the the claim about what has been
learned is uh
not
found in the actual science that was
done it was not is not found in the
actual science and you know there are
places where this can actually happen to
you honestly right like places where you
submit an abstract to a conference for
work you're doing the work will be done
by the time you present it and the point
is your abstract is a pretty good guess
at what you will present but you may
discover that it's not exactly in fact
um uh charles handley who was one of my
bat mentors uh used to say may all your
abstracts come true um so just i mean
we've talked about this before here but
just the way that academic
academic communication one of the ways
that academic communication happens like
the first
pass especially for um especially for
young researchers and especially for
research that people think is going to
be very important
has been at least in the past this may
actually be changing with social media
frankly but it has been until very
recently
the conference right so there are annual
conferences for all of you know all of
the major organizations and you can
parse it in lots of different ways you
know it can be organism over in our
space it could be evolution it could be
animal behavior it could be you know
molecular biology it can be you know
mammals specific it can be lots of
different ways
but you have to
submit an abstract to be accepted or
rejected for um to be able to give a
talk at a conference many many months um
sometimes well more than half a year in
advance of actually giving the talk and
very often the field season during which
or you know or the or the lab work for
us it was always field season but the
field season during which you're
actually going to be doing the work that
you're hoping to talk about hasn't yet
happened so you have to take a guess and
this this also is the case for um
permits like i found i found myself in
madagascar
arguing in bad french with some
bureaucrat about um
my inability to explain to him exactly
what i was going to learn in the next
five months which is the reason that i
was trying to get permits to study these
frogs it's like you know if i already
knew i wouldn't be here i wouldn't need
to be doing the research
so you know there are a lot of these
um you know bureaucratic solutions
uh in order to make scheduling easier in
order to make paperwork easier um that
reveal a just a like a tragic
misunderstanding of what discovery is
and of what science is
right and so there are organic ways that
your abstract can be a mismatch for what
your study produces
this one ain't that right not only was
this a paper published in the standard
way in a high
profile journal
right with top tier editors
presumably top tier peer reviewers but
it's delayed
by seven months in an environment where
things have been rushed this one was
delayed and so the point is the number
of opportunities for somebody to say
what they were
scientifically obligated to say which is
we can't tell what you did
right
you may have done
what was necessary to get to that
conclusion but it damn well better be in
the methods section and if you know
smart people can't figure it out from
what you said then that's on you
so smart people some of whom are
specialists in exactly the fields uh for
whom this should be this is a second
language right um can't are having a
hard time figuring it out so they're
having a hard time figuring it out that
is
that is
a technique
used in some cases by some scientists in
both writing and speaking
um in order to sound like they are smart
but not actually um interested in being
understood right it is it can be an
obscuring technique um i do not
um
i am not claiming that's what's going on
here and it certainly sounds like even
if there is any of that it's a whole lot
of other things as well
but the idea that
scientists need not
focus on communicating what it is that
they have learned
is
is archaic and regressive and wrong and
it may be that some scientists um need
not think about what it is that their
you know that their message would be to
the outside world like that's what
science journalists are for
excuse me but
being able to communicate what it is
that you've done and what it is that you
think you've learned and what it is that
you think it means are absolutely
necessary parts of the scientific
process
necessary parts of the scientific
process that as soon as they fail what
you are doing is not science right the
philosophy of science depends on these
things being done correctly so that
somebody else can figure out i mean the
fact is we're all not good at figuring
out every error that we make right
sometimes we catch them sometimes we
don't so the point is built into this
whole mechanism
is the ability to for others to
scrutinize what you did if we can't even
figure out what it was then we can't get
to the stage where we say well okay does
that result in your conclusion being
robust is there a confound what younger
people call confounders
that you know you should have spotted
that may have been important
i i think i've said this before but i
actually believe the younger people are
right to call them confounders um i just
think it's linguistically more correct
than what we say but it sure sounds
wrong to me
um
all right anyway
that's the long and short of it i would
say people should be paying i should say
there's a clock ticking as i understand
it that there is a retraction clock
that if you're going to request that a
journal retract a study that has
published in this case there's a short
window to do it and so in this case
because this journal has a shorter than
the average window or because this paper
has been given a shorter than average
window for the journal i believe it is
the journal's policy but the point is
that clock is short relative to the
amount of effort that a large group of
smart well-informed people need in order
to figure out even what was done let
alone whether it
reaches the conclusion naturally so
anyway this is you know i'm sure
that if the
paper any paper turns out to be nonsense
after that clock has expired the new
england journal of medicine has a
mechanism for retracting it but the
point is to request the retraction they
have very severe limits on how much you
can say and how long you have to say it
you know
which may be more bureaucratic solutions
uh for problems that don't necessarily
fit into bureaucratic rules but i i also
understand the constraint right like you
know you would need you know just like
the statute of limitations for you know
for for crimes
there needs to be limits so that people
can't come back and you know we would
definitely see especially you know as
the you know trans activists would be
asking for all sorts of things to be
retracted now right but okay so i have
argued in many places uh including lots
of stuff in and around game b
that um
a complex system that is well managed a
human system
has to be
uh well managed with discretion right
you need individuals with just
discretion so to the extent that there
might be a clock for a standard thing
there ought to be a way to send an email
to the editor and say in this case the
clock shouldn't apply because there's
too much resting on it and the
complexity of the methods is too great
for us
to be expected and a formal request for
an extension sure
[Music]